let's get your thoughts on this so here
so the this is cnbc they broke this down
um
they said who number one i want to get
your guys thoughts who do you think
spends more
collectively on valentine's day new
couples two years or less or couples
that have been together longer two years
or more who do you think and i'll give
you the numbers i think new couples
because it's like more exciting and
you're really like celebrating it and
showing it off got it so you're going
with new couples dr nicholson yes i'm
going with old couples because i think
or couples who have been together
together
because you have more baggage and
they're probably trying to do this
compensation thing to make up for it
that's the make good day yeah that's it
you know i was leaning towards younger
but i think now i i want to say okay
well
uh happy to say the queen got it right
here we go according to cnbc
new couples
spend on average 250 during the holiday
whereas couples have been together
longer than two years only spend 175
and then they break it down by
generation so they say gen z spends x
millennial spends x gen x and then baby
boomers of those who do you think spends
the most gen z which is basically like
college-aged uh people in their you know
early 20s millennials 30s ish
gen x that's uh rollo's age like in
their
40s 50s or boomers 65 plus who do you
think spends the most i feel like the
youngest group what was it jen uh
because you have to flex on the gram
you do gotta flex on the gram how about
you i cannot say anything as trendy as
you just did but i'm going to go with
millennials okay you're going with
millennials i'm going to go with
millennials as well certainly because i
think that like when you look at like
the statistics for guys
you know being sexless
these days it's usually gen z that's the
that contributes to that that majority
okay so you're you're saying that's what
i'm doing i gotta rationalize it all the
queen
is wrong this time you guys got it right
it was the millennials spend shockingly
more than any other generation gen z
spends on average 164
millennials almost 300 294.
gen x 182 and boomers ain't spending
[ __ ] on one another they've been married
forever they're spending 120 bucks okay
get me out of here now here are the most
common purchases
on valentine's day the overwhelming me
uh overwhelmingly allowed why can't i
say that word overwhelmingly
uh majority of people spend uh money on
candy 56
then cards 40 then flowers 37 percent
than jewelry 22 so does lingerie even
figure out i was thinking
well let's have that conversation about
lingerie who's are you buying that for
your wife is it your man you want your
man to buy that i think the woman would
buy it to gift her presence it's like
here's a present for you
lingerie that i'm gonna wear that's how
i've done it too i'm good with that okay
now where do handcuffs fit in here that
says that two percent people
buy handcuffs has that ever been a
purchase you've made you're an aquarian
you should know this yeah well you know
yes should a man buy lingerie for a
woman or should a woman buy lingerie for
herself and then i think
yeah
well i've been this is it is it a
different like impetus i guess is there
like something like is a different
message if he buys it for you as opposed
to you buying for him to want to turn
him on i'm thinking
do you have this right now
is it different yeah
but like i feel like if you as the
female are buying the lingerie i mean i
even buy lingerie single i do it for
themselves of the lingerie you own how
much did you buy and how much did the
other gu like i got to buy for you
um
mostly i i bought most of it myself but
sometimes i'll like go shopping with a
guy
and he'll buy it for him yeah i've been
that dude by the way quite frankly like
we're going it's a shopping day we're
going to victoria see if queen
victoria's secret it's like okay i'm
there i'm a [ __ ] boyfriend i'm
walking in it and i just stand there
like a schmuck like all the other
boyfriends do and we're like pretending
to only focus on our girl but there's
like a hot girl okay all right i'm just
keeping it focused but then
you don't want to get the girl like the
wrong size like as a guy you understand
it's like i got you a medium you know
i'm a [ __ ] small it's like
i worked at victoria's secret for a
while oh really i specialized in men who
looked very uncomfortable and lost bingo
yes so what'd you do to these men say
hey because these guys know when they
walk in the store whatever their girl
wants they're gonna be terrified yeah
they're not gonna be like i don't know
honey that lingerie's a little expensive
it's like dude you're in the [ __ ]
lion's den
like you're spending money whatever it
is brah is it brother like 50 bucks a
pop boom you're buying four or five bra
some lingerie like you're gonna spend
four or five hundred bucks no problem
all they wanted was direction would you
coach these guys up let's hear this i
would say
how big is she
okay how big is this girl
what are we dealing with first off it's
like what is she like does she like
something lacy does she like something
cuddly like what uh what area of the
store are we going into is she not there
no the dudes are watching christmas time
and so yeah there's always these men
well they're so low yeah they were
mortified it was it's like it's like a
girl going onto a car lot by herself
yeah instead of like the guy goes on to
into a lingerie store by himself
they play vulnerable you could just get
a gift card for that
after this no like i'd rather
and we would narrow it down so are we
here are we here does she went garter so
like and they'd be like
yes
why were they nervous i don't know they
were intimidated was it by you was it by
the shopping i mean you're tall you're
both very tall and lovely so like i can
see why people would be intimidated
especially if it's like i don't know
what am i doing in this store the next
time i will take exit interviews and
have that information yes please give us
that information well here's a here's a
question
we're talking we're setting the table
here but ultimately you're coming with
the five love languages yeah one of them
is gifting right there's uh so where do
you guys stand on the gifting component
you've been married 25 years 26 years
you know for instance i think there's
like active service physical uh
physical touch physical affectionation
quality time like every girl i'm with is
like god you want my quality i'm like we
spend every second ago that's not
quality time
there's um
[Music]
acts of service quality time physical
touch gifting
and words of affirmation exactly big so
rolo where do you and your wife stand on
the gifting
category
i think that it would be a different
situation between myself and my wife
like when we talk about uh
gifts or compliments or cards or
whatever it's usually um
when i'm talking to guys about that they
say oh should i give her a gift or nine
times out of ten it's like a guy is
giving a woman flowers to make up for
something to tell oh i screwed up so i'm
gonna have to in fact whenever you're
like in an office situation and suddenly
the you know the front desk girl gets
flowers you go oh that guy must have
[ __ ] up you know that's i mean that's
what we think right now it's not it's
not just simply a compliment or it's
it's not like uh you know
maybe it's a holiday or something like
that but if it's not a holiday then it's
usually some guy who's trying to make up
for for a bad about a misstep and i
think that's kind of like crazy because
that's the presumption we have because
men have a burden of performance and if
they screw up in that burden of
performance they're always trying to
find ways to sort of catch up and make
up to that and so when it comes to like
gifts and compliments and cards it i i
think guys really need to look at it
more as sort of um
like a reward like if something was like
if if you had really great sex the night
before or if you uh if maybe you were
you something that i have really great
sex with someone and they give me a card
well flowers or something you were
[ __ ] great last night congratulations
thank you keep up the good work that's
not so
as far as love languages are concerned
it's like what what's the next pop
psychology i mean i i've been in a
relationship for uh with my wife for
well technically 26 years we have
married for 25. and i will tell you
right now that a good relationship a
healthy relationship has polarity and it
also has um
it's effortless i hate it when people
say we're working on a relationship i
agree with you you're not you're not
working on your relationship he's
working on the relationship to measure
up to what your expectations are and
that's where you come in with like gifts
and flowers and everything else to sort
of how am i going to make her happy
today kind of thing rather and so it
becomes this obsessive like you know
lifelong project as opposed to like
we're going and doing life together what
did you mean by polarity because i've
dealt with some bipolarity
but girls what do you mean by they're
already in the sense that you both
retain your own identities okay and i
think because because usually i mean
today anyways i would argue that most
men lose their identities in the like
trying to become what that woman you
know expects the anticipations the
entitlements that that woman has of that
guy within that relationship and again
that plays back into what i call the
men's burden of performance and guys
take that very seriously it's like this
is how you be a good husband and a good
you know boyfriend or this or what i'm
going to be the perfect guy and the
problem is is that those guys don't
understand that perfect is boring hmm
boring
what do you have any uh insight on what
are you saying either you're ladies uh
boring perfect what's that i
personally like um
appreciated the part that you said where
like you shouldn't be trying to change
yourself it should be easy
however i'm a gift giver and so i
like when men are also like i even for
my friends like i'm always giving gifts
i just that's how i communicate like as
the five love languages
um so i like when a guy is thoughtful
and giving gifts and i i don't think it
should be oh
he's giving me flowers because he messed
up it's like he's giving me flowers
because i'm beautiful like that's just
the way that i
um conceptualize my world and
for the question of how do we like
what's our love language was that it
mine is quality time like that's how i
receive
[Music]